[Music]
[Applause]
bob condoda covers the seahawks for the
seattle times kind enough to join us
after last night's festivities what was
the build-up like this past week bob to
this matchup
um what was yeah pretty much what you'd
expect i mean obviously a lot of a lot
of excitement and eagerness and a lot of
people curious to see how how this was
going to turn out with russell coming
back i mean he's um you know he's he's
by far i think you know i think no
offense to matt hasselbeck but i think
he's the best quarterback in team
history and probably the probably about
the most important player in team
history with with being the finishing
piece on
on the team that won the city it's only
super bowl but obviously there was a lot
of contentiousness over the last two
years basically and
leading up into the trade so
you know there's a lot of mixed and
conflicting emotions and i think you saw
that come out at the stadium last night
i guess i was a little bit surprised and
i know this is outside looking in and
that is there was really no
acknowledgement or tribute to russ prior
to the game it felt like as soon as he
walked out that was it we don't know who
you are we don't care who you are and i
was just wondering about that that even
when brady went back to new england i
mean they did give a little bit of a
tribute of video tribute to him so
why was there
no grace period or a hey we'll spend
three minutes now we move on and you're
the opposition
yeah i you know i didn't ask that
question specifically of anybody so i
guess i don't know if the organization
considered it um but i think that goes
in a little bit with pete carroll's
always compete kind of thing that you
know that he's on the side he's on the
other side now and there's that there'll
be a time and place for doing that you
know maybe maybe 10 or 15 years from now
when everybody's careers are over
so that's a long time bob yeah yeah well
i but as you know you know better than
anybody you know russell sort of wanted
out you know so i think they're like you
know are you gonna you know a guy who
guy who wanted out of town are we then
gonna just kind of welcome welcoming
back with open arms the one time he
comes back as as the opponent you know
so i i think there's some of that at
play here you know i think it's uh i i
mean we all know this wasn't you know
this wasn't the the totally smooth the
tour yeah but in fairness to russ and i
don't want to be the rust whisperer but
you know that story that came out in
2018 is they were they were going to
trade they were in trade rush to
cleveland to get you know uh the number
one pick in the draft and they were
going to take
josh josh allen so i don't know how
close that i don't know how close i i
mean i i don't know that that was more
than about a three-minute conversation
that was just sort of a you know would
you actually entertain this i think that
was more of the seahawks just kind of
trying to see if anybody even would do
something like that at that time okay
kind of trying to gauge the market i
thought there was a report that came out
that that was acknowledged and also
you know yeah i'm saying i think i do
yeah i do think they talk that but i
don't think it was it was we'll do it if
you say yes i don't think it was that
close i think it was more of a you know
just two gm's talking kind of thing but
do you think pete
like
they didn't even acknowledge each other
on the field pregame i don't think they
did not pre-game they did after the game
but yeah they no they they didn't
pre-game but
i don't know that they were on the field
together a whole lot um you know i russ
sort of did his his pregame thing you
know pretty early and
pete was you know and maybe pete
intentionally wasn't out there that
early but a lot of times he's not uh you
know the two hours prior to the game
thing when everybody's out there and
then once you know once the teams are
out there doing their doing their things
together but again i i don't it's pretty
obvious isn't it to the outside world
this wasn't a happy breakup so you know
i you know i don't know if if you see
your ex-wife at some social function do
you then kind of go up and ask like you
act like you're best friends um you know
the first time you see him i usually do
a video tribute healing time is going to
be needed here yeah i would do a video
tribute if i was you know married before
and you know i saw my ex-wife i
you know i'd always do that okay so i
think a lot of people on the outside
looking in thought seattle maybe they're
tanking that they didn't really make a
move you know their move is they traded
russ and they got drew lock and he's not
good enough to beat out geno smith
but here you are winning a game so
what is the philosophy of the seahawks
this year in you know winning and losing
games
well it's to win as many games as they
can i i don't know that that's any
different than it's ever been and you
know they've never stated that
they feel like they have a pretty strong
roster otherwise and you know i think
that's what showed up a little bit last
night was with their defense you know
pete carroll is uh you know this is i
think pete carroll's pretty excited
about this team believe it or not
because i think it's the kind of team
that plays the way he wants to play
which again is at the heart of the
matter of why russell wilson is on the
other side now um you know he likes he
likes a team that leads with its defense
and doesn't turn the ball over
and uh
but you know they didn't really have a
strong running game last night which if
there's something from a seattle
standpoint to just sort of be concerned
about it that you know i think they
really wanted to run the ball a lot more
a lot better than they did um obviously
the second half was a little bit of a
slog offensively for them but um but you
know a lot of the rest of the things
they did you know they didn't commit a
lot of penalties they didn't turn the
ball over um you know that's all right
up pete alley and i think he thinks this
is a team that could do that and if they
could get adequate quarterbacking play
that they can be a competitive team this
year um you know for all the tacos that
they just want to try to get a
quarterback out of the draft next year i
you know i i do think that's certainly
um
in in the thinking but with you know the
two the two first-round picks they have
and the two second round picks they have
i think they feel like that's something
they could get done even without going 2
and 15 or whatever you know that they
have the ammo to you know they'll have a
ton of cash face with what once russell
comes completely off the books next year
as well um you know so that they'll have
the cap space and the draft pick ammo to
if they need to make a trade to move up
to try to get a certain guy that they
want that they'll be able to do it that
way
how surprised were you that the broncos
went for the field goal as opposed to
letting russ go for fourth and five
yeah i was really surprised by that i
didn't i wasn't in the moment i wasn't
even expecting that
you know i think we were all up there
wondering why they're letting the clock
run the way they were it was like this
is really odd clock management they
don't seem to be in a hurry here and um
and they had the three time out so it
was it was definitely curious and
you know i everybody seemed to say the
right things afterward on the denver
side i saw russell said he didn't think
it was a bad decision and all that so um
you know who knows but yeah i i was i
was really surprised by that because you
know fourth and five is not a you know
that's not fourth and 25 so um it's
certainly it's certainly a gettable
distance and there's an awful lot of
things that could happen and um so for
sure yeah i was definitely surprised by
that how loud was it compared to other
games in that building
um there have been an awful lot of loud
games so i i don't know that it was you
know any louder than some of the really
big games they've played through the
years you know like the
you know the two nfc championship games
and some of the other games in that era
but it felt more like that than the
games of the past year certainly um you
know i obviou
you know last year they they didn't get
off to a great start and you know there
weren't there
weren't necessarily a ton of really
super exciting moments um
there last year so it definitely felt
like you know kind of the prime time
games certainly the pre-game scene was
you know the the words a lot of people
used was it was kind of surreal with
with seeing russell on the other side
and there was certainly some buoy
directed toward him and um
you know so that that was certain that
was a little bit different than you
often see there
well good to talk to you bob and uh
thanks for joining us
okay all right thanks
that's uh bob kondoda he covers the
seahawks for the seattle time